vous êtes là pour la retraite de dix
jours nous tous version 2.0 exactement
il semblerait que j'ai besoin qu'on me
réparé
bienvenue au centre tranquille m
vous voulez vous sentir mieux vous
voulez guérir
je ne veux pas souffrir vous êtes déjà
en train de souffrir
le petit déjeuner est à cette heure le
déjeuner à midi le dîner à 19h30
et il ya combien de clients ici neuf en
tout
ces centres de bien-être chez les
conneries tout simplement sauf que vous
êtes là
on va méditer
à présent je veux que vous fermiez tous
les yeux
voulez vous sentir mieux vous voulez
guérir
abandonnez vous à moi
[Musique]
parce que je veux vous aider
tel quoi ton histoire j'en ai aucune
tout le monde a une histoire
c'est pour ça que vous nous avez choisi
choisi commence à
noter montceau complète les uns les
autres
tu m'aimes
je crois que je suis pas supposé être
ici je vote qu on laisse une chance à
leurs cocktails et qu'on accepte
d'explorer d'autres voies certaines voix
ne sont pas explorables
oui tout ça c'était des conneries j'en
sais [ __ ] à rien
nous rezidor forme un ensemble
particulièrement explosif lançant le
protocole i
je crois pas qu'ils sont prêts
c'est absolument sans danger
je ne me suis pas sentie moi même
[Applaudissements]
la pression il ya quelque chose qui
t'ont par an cette femme a choisi neuf
personnes prêtes à accepter de se prêter
à toutes ces expériences
vous avez perdu l'esprit
il n'y a aucune raison d'avoir peur
parce que ces protocoles
causera une vraie révolution
[Musique]
les folles où elle est vraiment sincère